would we need yet another investigation
into another member of his top team even
now number 10 says the party chair
retains the prime minister's full
confidence how can the Prime Minister
claim to deliver the Integrity
professionalism and accountability that
he promised while his conservative party
chair still sits in his cabinet
I have
thank you Mr Speaker the
we follow a proper process under the
ministerial code interests are required
to be declared they are required to be
shared through the ministerial process
and discussed with uh permanent
secretaries I am absolutely confident
that the usual process would have been
followed in the appointment process by
this prime minister for the right
honorable gentleman
and if there are issues to be raised in
respect of historic activities as was
suggested by this weekend's press that
is a matter for the independent advisor
to look at and his findings the summary
of His findings will be published in due
course Integrity accountability are
critical as is professionalism
and this government will wait and hear
the facts before taking decisions based
upon those facts and I think the right
Rumble lady would do well to do the same
follow
-up uh Mr Speaker I think it's a great
shame that the processes of the
proprietary and ethics team of our civil
service are being called into disrepute
by the comments by The Honorable lady
opposite we have to accept in public
life there are times when you may be
asked to serve in government
when you go through that process you are
required quite rightly to disclose
absolutely everything that might cause
conflict with you being a minister of
the crowd does my right honorable friend
agree that that process can only survive
when there is both confidentiality about
your disclosures and tolerance on all
sides whilst that process is completed
all right Mr Speaker I thank my
honorable friend uh for what he said is
absolutely right there is for for people
being called into government there is a
proper process there is a requirement
for full disclosure and for that process
to continue to be meaningful and to work
into for decades into the future you
need to retain confidentiality
confidentiality has to be part of it and
the Right Way Forward when an issue has
been raised is for the independent
advisor to look into it as indeed he is
doing smp's spokesperson John Nicholson
uh thank you very much Mr Speaker here's
what we know about the appointment of
the BBC chair the BBC chair Richard
Sharp helped arrange a 600 000 pound
loan for the right honorable member for
Uxbridge and South Royston weeks before
he was chosen by the former prime
minister to become BBC chair
Mr Sharp appeared before the culture
select committee on which I sit we
grilled them about his four hundred
thousand pound gift to conservative
party however he did not disclose his
role in getting the man appointing him a
huge loan
Mr Sharp the former prime minister and
the cousin offering the loan dying
together Checkers pre-loan and
pre-appointment the former prime
minister's spokesperson says so what big
deal
the capital office ethics team told the
former prime minister to stop talking to
Mr Sharp about his finances ministers
told other applicants not to waste their
time applying the appointment was to go
to the right honorable member for Oxford
and South ruislip's friend the Tory
donor even by The Grubby standards of
this government it's all a bit Banana
Republic is it not
[Music]
Mr Mr Speaker
um I thank the honored for his question
uh as The Honorable gentleman knows
there was a very robust process in place
for the appointment of the chairman of
the BBC including a pre-appointment
hearing I I read the transcript this
morning on which audible Jumpman played
as usual uh prominent role in grilling
uh uh the uh the appointee
pre-appointment uh it was an incredibly
robust process with an independent panel
of five uh members that went through
that process and just to reassure the
house I understand that the commissioner
in public appointments is going to
double check that that went through a
process was absolutely consistent uh
with the proper governance uh expected
of uh these appointments and I know that
the chairman of the BBC has invited the
senior non-executive director of the BBC
to discuss with the board to make
certain that all relevant uh conflicts
of interest were properly uh disclosed
so there are two processes that are
ongoing but this was a very robust
process Angela Richards thank you Mr
Speaker I shouldn't be astonished but I
am astonished at the brass neck of the
Shadow leader of the opposition for
suggesting that the Prime Minister
didn't need to ask his independent
advisor on this when they spent months
calling for an independent advisor to be
appointed is my right honorable friend
aware of any plans by the independent
advisor to publish an updated list of
ministerial interests
Minister uh I Thank The Honorable lady
and she's absolutely right the other
side of this house have been calling for
independent advisor for months one gets
appointed and it's not good enough you
need to take all Decisions by yourself
devoid of all the facts and it is useful
to have an independent advisor in hand
to deal with these issues when it is
appropriate and yes to reassure The
Honorable lady my understanding is that
the independent advisor plans to a
publication or ministerial interest
prior to his report in May Karen Smith
thank you um Mr Speaker the public
administration Constitution the first
committee is ready to help and looks
forward to meeting the new ethics
advisor I think
Mr has said the Prime Minister has said
that there are questions to be answered
the minister has been very careful to
say that the filling of the ministerial
code is up to the individual which is
which is correct so is he uh trying to
tell us does the Prime Minister did the
Prime Minister know that the member for
Stratford was due to be investigated
minister
uh the Prime Minister will have had the
benefit of the usual appointments
process being undertaken so he would
have had full disclosure uh regarding
the interests of the right honorable uh
gentleman as disclosed at the time when
the Prime Minister made his appointment
as chairman of the conservative party
Mr Speaker the prime minister's
correctly asked his independent advisor
or Mr interests to establish the facts
on this matter
this is my advice my girlfriend agree
that we must not Prejudice the outcome
and allow this process to conclude
I I do agree Mr chair Mr Speaker that is
the purpose of having an independent
advisor uh he's been asked to
investigate to work out exactly what the
facts are and we should not it's it's
ill judge to pre uh decide before you
actually know all the facts that pertain
that is that process we're undergoing at
the moment
Christine jaldi thank you very much Mr
Speaker I'm sure we all remember that
first speech from Downing Street when
the Prime Minister promised us Integrity
professionalism and accountability at
every level unfortunately we've seen
precious little evidence of that so far
and this weekend yet more doubt has been
heaped in the minds of the electorate my
constituent certainly about whether they
can trust politicians in general so does
the minister accept that unless
something is done very quickly about the
vetting and management of conflicts of
interest further damage is going to be
done in the confidence in this place the
British public
we have the Nolan principles and we have
the ministerial code both are extremely
important documents and extremely
important approaches uh The Honorable
lady refers to professionalism and and
she's right but part of professionalism
is making certain you take decisions
based on all the facts and I know she'll
respect the fact that it is useful to
have those established but I conceded
her definitely that it should be
established swiftly David Johnson thank
you Mr Speaker does my honorable friend
agree that um beneath the Bluster from
the benches opposite what they're really
saying is there's various information
they don't know the answer to that they
don't have the facts about not least
because hmrc doesn't comment on the
individual tax Affairs of of people and
therefore it's absolutely right the
independent advisor should be allowed to
collect those facts and publish them to
set the record straight
Minister uh indeed I got absolutely no
doubt my right honorable friend will
cooperate in every way with the uh
independent advisor to make certain that
all the facts are known he will go
through that process the independent
advisor in due course will countries
conclusions and the summarized
conclusions will indeed be published
Richard Bergen thank you Mr Speaker the
Prime Minister stood on the steps of 10
Downing streets and promised the nation
that he would act with integrity and yet
here we are again isn't this whole
Affair yet another point of proof that
where there are conflicts of interest
it's far more likely you're going to
have conflicts of interest when you've
got a government of the super rich for
the super rich
I'd have a question along those lines
from The Honorable gentleman
Integrity accountability and
professionalism that is absolutely right
that absolutely underpins this
government and part of that is making
certain you have the facts and that is
what we are undertaking to do through
the auspices of the independent advisor
thank you madam David speaker the
ministerial code seems to now be a set
of guidelines this is starting to sound
like a script from Pirates of the
Caribbean
but uh can I can I ask the minister if
if someone is disclosed that they are in
dispute with the Inland Revenue about
their taxes
appropriate to then appoint that person
as the chancellor of the exchequer
surely the the that that matter should
have been resolved before such an
appointment took place
yes sir uh The Honorable after excuse me
I do not know uh what was disclosed and
nor does The Honorable gentleman that is
why we have an independent advisor
making certain that we have the facts
addressed
so Stephen tombs thank you speak up the
current chairman of the conservative
party went on to television but before
he settled his tax debt and said that
his tax Affairs were quote fully paid
and opted out we now know that statement
was untrue don't we
minister
uh I've got a great deal of respect for
the entrepreneur but he knows I don't
know the answer to that question I don't
generally don't
um but I got every I've got no doubt
that the work of the independent advisor
will establish uh the facts and that
that will be reported to the prime
minister
and it's Stella Priestley thank you
madam Deputy speaker the challenge here
for the minister is that the original
allegations arose in July of last year
publicly and subsequent evidence that
indeed lawyers were instructed to try
and suppress those allegations well
before any appointment made by his
political party or indeed by the Prime
Minister now the minister talks about
allegations arising this weekend whose
due diligence was lacking is it the
cabinet office is it the conservative
office or are we just not being told the
whole truth on this matter thank you
Minister the full process would have
been undergone in terms of uh my radical
friend's appointment to the government
of chairman of the conservative party or
appointment to the cabin office uh when
he was appointed by this prime minister
that was clearly appearing after the
July uh commentary in the Press so I
don't know what was uh disclosed I
mentioned everything was disclosed but
that is a matter for the independent
advisor to ascertain
and that show
BBC journalists have to spend a great
deal of their time defending the BBC's
impartiality and integrity from
criticisms from all sides in this
country how is their job made easier by
the Revelation that the current BBC
chairman involved himself in the private
financial affairs of the former prime
minister before he was appointed at the
job something that both he and the Prime
Minister should under Civil Service
rules and BBC rules have just have
disclosed to the independent
appointments commission which apparently
according to former commissioner sir
Peter riddle neither did
[Music]
yeah it is done my understanding is that
both what I don't remember for Uxbridge
uh and the gentleman in question have
both said uh that uh no Financial advice
was provided from one uh to the other
that's my uh understanding
um and I do know that the chairman of
the BBC has invited uh the senior
non-executive of the BBC to look into
his disclosures to make certain
everything was done properly uh
presidents that also will be undertaken
by William shawcross as a commissioner
for public appointments to make certain
that that process which appeared being
extremely robust process indeed involved
drilling before The Honorable gentlemen
and others in front of the select
committee uh will was uh absolutely
consistent with the government's rules
on these appointments
Kevin Brennan well actually that's an
interesting point the minister is just
making because on on that very point of
course before he appeared before the
select committee the candidate was had
to fill in a question and he had to
answer the question do you currently or
potentially have a business Financial or
non-pecuniary interest or commitment
that might give rise to the perception
of a conflict of interest if you are
appointed now doesn't the minister agree
that helping to arrange an 800 000 pound
loan for the person ultimate responsible
for your appointment should have been
declared in response to that question
[Applause]
but the honorable gentleman is making a
statement there about helping to arrange
a loan I don't know the basis on which
he makes that assertion but I know that
all matters to do with uh any any uh
conflicts of interest or perceptional
conflicts of interest are going to be
looked at by the BBC under that process
established by the chairman
thank you madam
Madam because
on Wednesday the Prime Minister stated
there were no outstanding issues by the
weekend the Prime Minister ordered an
independent investigation can the
ministry ensure that all of the
information that escalated this from
nothing to see to an internal
independent investigation is placed in
the library
Minister uh what is absolutely the case
is that the uh a summary of the findings
of the independent advisor and the
outcome of that work will be shared with
this house
it's done thank you madam Deputy speaker
a person is 23 times more likely to be
prosecuted for benefit of regularities
than tax irregularities yeah yeah tax
irregularities lose the economy nine
times more so does the government have
any plans to redress this imbalance
absolutely
Minister there is a huge Focus across
government and I know this when I work
inside the cabinet office in making
certain that we get after uh tax evasion
in all its forms it's incredibly
important that we do and that we cast
cut uh waste across government
particularly when it comes out of uh
fraudulent Behavior that's what we do uh
every day hmrc is responsible for
following up and making certain that
people pay the taxes owed age
Andy McDonald thank you Father Deputy
speaker I I just wanted to tell the
house from my constituents I'm hearing
that they are heartily sick and tired of
reading these stories incessantly about
tax irregularities cheek ching and fraud
and self the self-serving Elite and
faith in politics and in this
institution is an all-time law as it is
with the BBC in light of these
Revelations and the one common
denominator button Deputy speaker is
that party opposite and this is only
ever going to be cleaned up cleaned up
once this lot are out of the door and
out of the government
[Applause]
and I do think uh we have an incredibly
valuable organization in the form of the
BBC I for One support it and I think
it's uh unfortunate to start uh making
allegations about the whole whole of the
BBC on the basis of something the facts
of which are disputed
cat Smith
are there any other government ministers
currently in dispute with the hmrc
around their tax Arrangements Minister
um
this is a matter for individual
ministers to talk to the uh go through
the proper process for the ministerial
code that's what uh everybody does that
is a requirement under this government
has this been the requirement under all
governments so you have full disclosure
in that process and you need to talk to
your permanent secretary and it's
absolutely critical that no conflicts of
interest are established uh or um or
indeed perceived conflicts of interest
are established
Alex Cunningham very much by the deputy
speaker all the inquiry confirmed the
nature of the agreement between the
right honorable member for Stafford or
navy and hmrc
Minister I've got every confidence in my
right honorable friend the member from
stratford-upon-avon uh will in will be
totally open with the independent
advisor this is an independent advisor
conducting a report for the Prime
Minister and I'm sure he will be
absolutely uh open with independent
advisors so the facts can be fully
established
Toby Perkins thank you uh Deputy speaker
with respect the minister is attempting
to balance on the head of a pin with
regard to Richard Sharp's involvement in
the loan to the Prime Minister former
prime minister he may not have provided
advice he may not have arranged it but
he clearly was involved in the
introduction and on that basis should he
not have made the Declaration referred
to by honorable friend from Cardiff West
when he appeared in front of the
committee
minister
the obviously Mr Sharp felt that that
was not uh required that was not uh the
case uh I understand that uh a process
was uh put in place to separate him from
the uh the loan arrangements and as I
say Mr Sharp has asked the senior
non-executive director at the BBC uh to
ensure that all matters in terms of
disclosure were followed correctly by
him in his process
tell us if any government ministers were
informed that the conservative party
chair was blocked for from receiving an
honor and if so did the government take
any action after receiving that news
Minister
um I genuinely don't know the answer to
that question
um Madame Deputy speaker that there is a
process for honors and awards uh which
has kept highly confidential I don't
know whether the right honorable
gentleman was up for an award or indeed
uh whether that was blocked so if it
would have been a very tight process I
don't know if there's any ministerial
involvement in that process
thank you very much speaker here we go
once again debating after being angered
by the lack of ethics and alleged
serious wrongdoing by government
ministers but despite the Prime Minister
making big promises about integrity
professionalism and accountability we
know he is going to do diddly squat
about it because he is too weak because
he is beholden to those very cabinet
ministers to cling on to power somehow
so does the minister not think that the
British people will smell a rat if they
see the conservative party chairman who
who act as Chancellor was supposed to be
in charge of the government's finances
at the time whilst trying to strike a
multi-million pound tax deal with the
hmrc for alleged serious wrongdoing okay
uh The Honorable gentleman's view of the
government of mine come from different
perspectives I've got a huge amount of
time for my right on defend the Prime
Minister who's leading this government
in the right directions and I have to
say that he is unwise I think to make uh
to to take a view on the uh outcome of
an inquiry that has not yet uh properly
commenced but it will the independent
advisor will get there and will
establish the facts Simon Lightwood
thank you madam Deputy speaker can the
minister confirm whether the right
honorable member for Stratford or navy
will make us tax Affairs transparent to
any investigation by the independent
advisor and can the minister confirm
that the Prime Minister will set that as
a requirement of the investigation
Minister uh
I Thank The Honorable for this question
as I absolutely make clear I would I I
cannot imagine circumstance under which
my right honorable friend would not wish
to be fully transparent uh with the
independent advisor that would be
necessary for him to do his his job and
uh that will enable him to establish the
facts
so Chris Bryant thank you madam speaker
I'm not going to get into the specifics
of the individuals concerned but
following on from the question from The
Honorable lady from Guildford
um I do want to know about the specifics
of why we don't have in the public
domain yet the financial interests of
all ministers the the list that's on the
website at the moment is 243 days old
it's not even an accurate list of
ministers it's not even an accurate list
of the last set of minutes or all the
set of ministers before that it's 90
days since this government was in place
there are people who are now ministers
who weren't even a member of either
house
um who uh so don't appear anywhere
surely surely the public
ought to know within a week or so of a
minister being appointed were all their
financial interests are why can't we
have that and why have we got to wait
another three months is what he said
earlier another three months before we
find out what all the financial
interests are of ministers we should
know it now
Minister it may be three months it may
be three hours but I'm going to speak I
said bye May is my understanding so I I
I can't commit to a date because I am
not the independent advisor
um and uh he has got work to do to
publish those but my understanding is
that uh there will be an updated list of
financial interest published uh in the
uh in uh before his report is out in May
that's my understanding thank you
Minister for asking me